>>> PRIMARY SEASON IS OFFICIALLY
OVER, AND ECTION DEN IRIS
HANDPIED BY FORMER PRESIDENT
DONALD TMP DOMINATED A LOT OF
REPUBLICAN RACES.
22 NOMINEES FOR GOVERNOR, 11
NOMINEES FOR SECRETARY OF STATE,
AND 19 NOMINEES FOR THE SENATE
EITHER REJECTED OR CAST DOUBT ON
THE 2020 ELECTION RESULTS.
CNN POLITICS REPORTER AND EDITOR
AT LARGE CHRIS ALIZZA SAYS THAT
MIGHT NOT BE THE GREATEST NEWS
FOR REPUBLICANS ON ELECTION DAY
COMING UP.
HE JOINS US NOW TO BREAK IT ALL
DOWN.
ALL RIGHT.
SO THE NEW HAMPSHIRE PRIMARY WAS
A BIT OF A CURIOUS ONE.
A MONTH AGO YOU HAD THE
NOW-REPUBLICAN NOMINEE FOR THE
SENATE BEING A DIEHARD ELECTION
DEN IRE TELLING EVERYONE THAT
TRUMP WAS ROBBED.
NOW HE'S SINGING A VERY
DIFFERENT TUNE.
>> IT'S REMARKABLE.
>> IT'S SHAMELESS.
>> IT REALLY IS -- THAT'S A GOOD
WORD FOR IT.
AUGUST 14th, THERE WAS A
REPUBLICAN PRIMARY DEBATE IN NEW
HAMPSHIRE.
BOLDUC, THE NOMINEE WHO YOU
REFERENCED, SAYS OUT AND OUT I
BELIEVE DONALD TRUMP WON THIS
ELECTION.
NO EQUIVOCATION, NO NOTHING.
THEN DON BOLDUC NOMINEE, HE WINS
NOMINATION ON TUESDAY, I THINK
WE HAVE SOUND, LET'S PLAY WHAT
HE SAID AFTER HE BECAME THE
REPUBLICAN NOMINEE ROUGHLY ONE
MONTH LATER.
>> I SIGNED A LETTER WITH 120
OTHER GENERALS AND ADMIRALS
SAYING THAT TRUMP WON THE
ELECTION AND DAMMIT, I STAND BY
MY WORDS.
I HAVE COME TO THE CONCLUSION
AND WANT TO BE DEFINITIVE ON
THIS.
THE ELECTION WAS NOT STOLEN.
WAS THERE FRAUD?
YES.
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS THE
LEGITIMATE PRESIDENT OF THIS
COUNTRY.
>> SO THE REMARKABLE THING IS
WHAT HE SAID IN THE LONGER CLIP
IS HE SAID, "I CONDUCTED MY OWN
INDEPENDENT INVESTIGATION, AND
I'VE JUST NOW REACHED THE
CONCLUSION," WHICH VERY
CONVENIENTLY HAPPENED AFTER HE
WON THE REPUBLICAN PRIMARY, THAT
IN FACT JOE BIDEN DID WIN.
THIS IS A POSITION THAT WE'VE
SEEN OTHER REPUBLICANS MAKE.
BLAKE MASTERS IN ARIZONA IS ONE
EXAMPLE.
SORT OF TRYING TO WALK BACK SOME
OF THE POSITIONS THAT THEY TOOK
IN A PRIMARY.
BUT WE HAVEN'T SEEN IT THIS
QUICKLY AFTER TAKING THE
POSITION, PAM.
I THINK IT SPEAKS TO THE
CHALLENGE REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES,
THEY HAVE TO BE IN THE ELECTION
DENIAL CAMP TO WIN REPUBLICAN
PRIMARIES, BUT THEN IN GENERAL
ELECTIONS THAT POSITION DOESN'T
FLY.
SO THEY'RE HAVING TO REALLY IN
BOLDUC'S CASE HAVING TO CHANGE
ON THE RUN.
>> RIGHT.
>> AND ANYONE WHO WATCHES THOSE
TWO SOUND BYTES CAN SAY THAT
DOESN'T REALLY FLY.
>> YEAH.
THEY DON'T HAVE ENOUGH TIME
BEFORE THE MIDTERMS TO LIKE
SLOWLY START TO PIVOT AWAY THERE
IT.
>> EASE AWAY FROM THEIR PAST
POSITION.
>> RIGHT.
THEY ONLY HAVE A COUPLE OF
MONTHS.
IN THE CASE OF NEW HAMPSHIRE.
ALL RIGHT.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THIS "NEW
YORK TIMES" POLL THAT CAME OUT
THIS WEEK.
IT CONFIRMED A DEMOCRATIC SURGE
OVER THE LAST FEW MONTHS.
LET'S LOOK AT THIS HERE.
FROM JULY TO SEPTEMBER,
DEMOCRATS SAY THE COUNTRY IS ON
THE RIGHT TRACK, HAVE GONE FROM
27% TO 50%, DEMOCRATS WHO SAY
THEY APPROVE OF BIDEN'S JOB
PERFORMANCE HAS GONE UP FROM 70%
NOW TO 83%.
WHY DO YOU THINK THIS IS?
>> A COUPLE THINGS.
ONE, I THINK BIDEN HAS GOTTEN
SOME WINS.
HE WAS SORT OF CONSTANTLY -- THE
INFLATION WAS UP, GAS PRICES
WERE UP.
THOSE ARE THINGS PEOPLE FEEL.
WHEN THEY GO TO THE STORE, IF
THINGS COST MORE, THEY FEEL
THAT.
IF THEY GO FILL UP GAS TANK AND
IT'S $75, THEY FEEL THAT.
THAT'S GONE AWAY A LITTLE BIT.
>> HOLD ON, THOUGH.
THE INFLATION -- GAS PRICES HAVE
GONE DOWN.
BUT INFLATION IS STILL --
>> IS STILL HIGH, BUT WE'RE NOT
SEEING SURGE, SURGE, SURGE.
I THINK THE OTHER THING IS
DONALD TRUMP HAS REEMERGED AND
BECOME A FACTOR IN THE ELECTION
AGAIN.
I THINK ANY TIME DONALD TRUMP
REARS HIS HEAD, THAT'S GOOD FOR
JOE BIDEN.
DONALD TRUMP IS NOT POPULAR
PARTICULARLY AMONG THE GENERAL
ELECTORATE.
I THINK THAT HELPS.
>> ALL RIGHT.
LET'S TALK ABOUT DONALD TRUMP
BECAUSE HE IS IN OHIO TO
CAMPAIGN FOR HIS CANDIDATE
THERE, J.D. VANCE.
TRUMP WON OHIO IN 2016, IN 2020.
THIS YEAR'S SENATE RACE IS
CLOSE.
VANCE LEADS BY JUST FOUR POINTS
OVER TIM RYAN.
COULD THIS BE A SIGN THAT
TRUMP'S POWER AMONG REPUBLICANS
IS DIMINISHING?
HOW SHOULD WE READ INTO THIS?
>> THE FACT THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT OHIO -- I'M TRYING TO
REMEMBER WHAT IT WAS -- 52 DAYS
I THINK BEFORE THE ELECTION --
THE FACT THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT OHIO SPEAKS TO THE FACT
THAT THE ELECTORATE ISN'T AS
TILTED TOWARD REPUBLICANS AS I
THINK WE MIGHT HAVE THOUGHT IT
MIGHT BE.
OHIO WAS A SWING STATE.
I REMEMBER WHEN I FIRST STARTED
COVERING THIS IN 2000, IF YOU
SAID WHAT'S THE SWING STATE IN
THE ELECTION, PEOPLE WOULD SAY
OHIO NATIONALLY.
IT'S TILTED MORE TOWARD
REPUBLICANS OF LATE.
DONALD TRUMP CARRIED IT TWICE.
AS A REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR MOST
OFFICIALS AT THE STATE LEVEL ARE
REPUBLICANS.
THERE IS NOT A STATE WHERE --
THIS IS NOT A STATE WHERE A
DEMOCRAT IN A MIDTERM ELECTION
YEAR, THE FIRST TERM MIDTERM.
A DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENT, THIS IS
NOT A STATE WHERE A DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSMAN SHOULD BE WITHIN
SHOUTING DISTANCE.
WHY IS HE?
I THINK THAT J.D. VANCE HAS BEEN
A PRETTY WEAK CANDIDATE.
PEOPLE KNOW HIM FROM BEST
SELLER, LOOK, I HAVE A BOOK
COMING OUT IN -- NEXT YEAR, I'D
LOVE FOR MY BOOK TO BE A
BESTSELLER, I DON'T BEGRUDGE HIM
THAT.
BUT AS A CANDIDATE HE HASN'T
BEEN AS SORT OF ABLE I THINK AS
REPUBLICANS HAD HOPED.
THIS IS ONE OF THE CANDIDATES
THAT DONALD TRUMP ENDORSED.
MEHMET OZ IN PENNSYLVANIA IS
ONE, HERSCHEL WALKER IN GEORGIA
IS ONE.
WE'VE SEEN THOSE CANDIDATES
STRUGGLE SOMEWHAT ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
SO I THINK HE'S LET TIM RYAN
INTO THE RACE.
THE QUESTION IS, NOW THAT IT'S
CLOSE, DOES IT STAY CLOSE?
AND YOU KNOW, REPUBLICANS, MITCH
McCONNELL'S LEADERSHIP PAC IS
SPENDING OVER $20 MILLION IN
OHIO.
THAT'S MONEY HE DIDN'T WANT TO
HAVE TO SPEND THERE.
IT'S MONEY HE WANTS TO SPEND IN
A PLACE LIKE GEORGIA, YOU KNOW,
IN OTHER OFFENSIVE
OPPORTUNITIES, COLORADO MAYBE
WHERE MICHAEL BENNETT IS UP FOR
RE-ELECTION.
SO IT SHOULDN'T BE CLOSE.
THE NUMBERS ON THIS YEAR IT
SHOULDN'T BE CLOSE.
THE FACT THAT IT IS SPEAKS TO --
TIM RYAN'S A PRETTY GOOD
CANDIDATE.
VANCE HAS STRUGGLED AS A
I NOT THE POLITICAL ENVIRONMENT
IS NOT AS TILTED TOWARD
REPUBLICANS AS WE MIGHT HAVE
THOUGHT IT WAS THREE MONTHS AGO.
>> I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT THIS
BECAUSE J.D. VANCE IS BEING
MOCKED BY HIS OPPONENT, TIM
RYAN, FOR HOLDING A RALLY
TONIGHT OPPOSITE AN OHIO STATE
FOOTBALL GAME.
I MEAN, DO ATTACKS LIKE THERE
REALLY WORK, OR ARE THEY JUST
SILLY?
>> SO -- WELL, AS A CHILD OF THE
SOUTH, YOU KNOW HOW BIG FOOTBALL
IS.
>> BASKETBALL WHERE I'M FROM.
THAT'S BIG, TOO.
>> KENTUCKY'S GOOD THIS YEAR.
>> WE'RE DEFENSE.
>> HERE'S WHAT I THINK -- A
ONE-OFF ATTACK LIKE THIS DOESN'T
NECESSARILY WORK.
IT DRAWS A LITTLE BIT OF
ATTENTION.
YES, YOU KNOW, HOLDATION RALLY
THE SAME NIGHT AS AN OHIO STATE
FOOTBALL GAME.
BUT IT CAN WORK IF IT FEELS LIKE
IT'S A PIECE OF A BROADER
ARGUMENT.
WHAT TIM RYAN'S TRYING TO SAY IS
J.D. VANCE ISN'T REALLY FROM
HERE.
J.D. VANCE DOESN'T GET US.
RIGHT, HE SAID SILICON VALLEY
J.D. VANCE.
HE DOESN'T GET WHO WE ARE, WHAT
WE CARE ABOUT, WE OHIOANS.
AND THAT'S OSU FOOTBALL.
SO IT CAN WORK AS PART OF THAT
BROADER PACKAGE.
I DON'T THINK A LOT OF VOTERS
ARE GOING INTO THE BALLOT BOX IN
NOVEMBER AND SAY, WELL, THEY DID
HAVE THAT TRUMP RALLY THE NIGHT
OF THE OSU/TOLEDO GAME.
I DON'T THINK THAT DECIDES IT.
PEOPLE VOTE FOR CANDIDATES THEY
FEEL IDENTIFY WITH THEM, WHETHER
IT'S THEY IDENTIFY WITH THEIR
HOPES, THEIR FEARS, THEIR
DREAMS.
IF YOU ARE OUT OF TOUCH OR
SEEING THIS AS OUT OF TOUCH,
INAUTHENTIC, THAT CAN BE BAD IN
A CAMPAIGN.
THAT'S WHAT TIM RYAN'S GOING
FOR.
WHETHER IT WORKS OR NOT, WE'LL
SEE.
YOU KNOW, I THINK J.D. VANCE IS
PROBABLY -- IT'S WORTH GETTING
THE ATTENTION AND THE REPUBLICAN
BASE RALLYING THAT DONALD TRUMP
COMING INTO THE STATE DOES FOR
HIM BECAUSE IT IS A
REPUBLICAN-TILTING STATE.
IF YOU HAVE A REPUBLICAN,
POPULAR REPUBLICAN PRESIDENT
WHICH DONALD TRUMP STILL IS IN
THE REPUBLICAN BASE, IT'S
PROBABLY WORTH THE HIT HE TAKES.
>> HE PROBABLY -- PROBABLY GOI